As the ice gradually receded, the countryside became green once more.
But the great beasts were no longer to be found.
We'll see it's out.
What's the matter?
Uh-huh.
How farming was born.
One come see!
Feds were modernized.
Agriculture became mechanized.
Centuries passed, as a Lithic or Middle Stone Age gave way to the Neolithic Age, the Age of Polished Stone.
We catch them!
And so, fences went up.
Houses became larger and were built in groups.
Hey, hey, would you tell me what's up here?
Huh? Stop right already!
Europe was still in its prehistory.
Karnak and Brittany.
Megaliths were having their heyday.
But at the same time, higher civilizations were thriving in the Middle East.
And in Asia.
Let's go back a few centuries.
5,000 years before Christ, Mesopotamia, where major cities flourished.
Jarmo in Iraq, Jericho in Palestine, and in Turkey, Shatel Hayouk.
these highly evolved peoples already knew how to alloy metals but it was in the fertile river
valleys that the first civilizations would take root along the indus mohenjo darrow
we're here you can either believe it or not my friends but my eyes have witnessed marvels the
city of mohenjo darrow is surrounded by walls incredibly high are comfortable upstairs and
down and they're built along wide avenues the women parade around quite resplendent in baubles
from head to toe the roadways are completely paved completely paved hey i've even seen a cart
on wheels wheels that's right a card on wheels ah no necklaces give us a break well yeah well
we know it's the truth maestro so may we discover the world with you tomorrow we'll set out for
other places over here fun then a mighty storm arose and fell in torrents for days and days
flood that came was the worst that anyone could remember the storm has passed and irrigation
becomes necessary once again the problem is no one can agree on anything each man works for
himself alone his first writing pictographs maestro scratches them onto clay tablets to tell
the story of this calamity, which one day will be called the Great Deluge. History would repeat
itself again and again. Let's try to work in harmony. There must be a way to connect canals
and dikes, to hold back the river when it floods. We must all work together united. All together,
but we're not used to doing anything that way. What's the use of it? No matter how you look at
it, it's not going to work anyway. Besides, why does he have to barge in anyway? And besides,
why does he have to barge in here anyway? You just mind your own business, buddy, or... Or what?
What, huh?
Well, we're going to waste precious time in talking instead of getting our work done.
Just look at those poor folks doing all that work for nothing.
We're supposed to do now.
To work together, to dig canals, deep ones, which we'll link up so the water can circulate.
And then we'll have to build up high dikes to protect village and crops.
The first collective labor.
Scattered groups joined and worked together.
The dawn of civilized society.
And before you know it...
Hmm, hmm.
All right, put beef behind it, good for nothing.
Hey, down there, get a bourbon.
You want to work with me?
Water's coming up quick.
Cover everybody.
Cheers.
See who's boss here.
Once brought under control, the river brought fertility, prosperity, and peace.
It was too good to last for long.
Call the shots here.
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
Let's go.
That's how it was, century after century.
A few hundred years later, along the River Nile, 2,700 years before our time.
Let's go! Let's go!
Don't let me catch you doing nothing again. Let's go! Come on!
Wacko, you all of you, halt, you nitwits!
His glory, the pharaoh, comes down to the river to command the waters to rise.
After all, according to the calculations of his priest, astrologist, and scholar, it's time.
And the river obeys. Fields flooded.
The thankful peasants go back to building the pyramid.
Chief, that guy, that big guy, he's being mean to me.
Stone, some weighing two tons, no tools for hoisting, no scaffolding, not a wheel in sight, a daily prison for more than 100,000 men.
The pharaoh died, along with him, his dreams of grandeur.
The Nile centuries and dynasties came and went.
Thirteen hundred years before our time, ruled Ramses II, the son and king of the Nile.
This is good.
Everything would be just fine if it weren't for tax collectors.
Move it, move it, step on over.
Sure, let's get a move on.
That's your share.
Get your hands off me!
Say, pal, that'll come in a late.
Have mercy, have mercy!
We'll get our basic cordy lashes.
I'm gonna make...
This was the final monument to the splendor of the pharaohs.
Look upon my works, ye mighty, and despair.
In later centuries came invasions by the Hyksos, war with the Hittites, as well as other misadventures.
Ten centuries later, in A.D. 30,
Cleopatra would choose suicide over surrender to Augustus and a 30-century cycle of history.
Back in 1250 B.C., the reign of Ramsey II had entered its 40th year.
My people are in slavery.
They are treated like beasts of the field.
The most cruel of tasks are theirs.
Hear me, O Pharaoh, let my people go.
Dare bring down the wrath of Yalva on you and your children.
Would you risk plague without number upon the people of Egypt?
And unto me, Pharaoh.
Pharaoh had no choice but to let the Israelites go, for they had a rendezvous with destiny.
They migrated further into the Sinai.
One day, of course we all know the story, but stop and take a look at some of the events.
Jericho.
The horn seven times, the walls will tumble down.
Samson and Delilah.
Good and Goliath.
My people, let's have some volunteers, and the one who makes this claw bite the dust will be given my daughter's hand in marriage.
What do you say, folks?
I'll show ya.
You.
*laughs*
*distant*
No, he's mine. No.
Alright, we'll share.
If she can keep him,
then he is yours. Take him.
As for you, wicked one, we will have to...
The Temple of Solomon.
Given. For the first time, men heard these words:
"Thou shalt not kill. Thou shalt not covet."
And men heard for the first time about one God.
Many centuries later, this belief would give rise to Christianity,
a concept that would shake the world.
And this was followed by Islam.